con cada tren que llega a este carril
humanitario de la estación kennedy de
budapest una nueva familia que ayudar la
mayoría son mujeres con sus hijos todas
vienen aterradas por lo que han dejado
atrás y temerosas de lo que puedan
encontrar en esta nueva ciudad donde la
mayoría no conoce a nadie kate es una de
ellas huyó de aquí con su hijo leo de 5
años
solo empaque las cosas importantes
aquellas que no podemos reemplazar
los días atrás fueron acogidos por una
pareja brasileña que como muchas
familias en budapest se han movilizado
para dar apoyo
venimos de brasil al otro lado del mundo
pero estamos aquí muy cerca de ucrania
así que todos tenemos que ayudar
30 bis a los suyos que se encuentra bien
su padre es alistado como voluntario y
su madre se negó a abandonar el país
el padre de leo dice que está más
tranquilo ahora porque su hijo está en
un lugar seguro
como ella cientos de mujeres van camino
hacia otros destinos hungría solo es un
lugar de paso
valentino yoga jarquín después de que la
ciudad fuera bombardeada estará el bazar
donde compraban comida nos cuenta
se dirige hasta muy junto con su hija y
tatiana a quien ha conocido en el camino
[Música]
de hecho yo estoy impresionada nunca me
imaginé ser acogida en polonia o hungría
de esta manera
saben que les espera un largo trayecto
pero siempre hay alguien dispuesto a
ayudar elianis es una de ellas en su
móvil guarda los rostros de las hábiles
que han acogido en su casa en estos días
ella entiende por lo que han pasado hace
unos años fue ella quien tuvo que
abandonar venezuela muchacha comenzó al
principio porque han tenido que salir
corriendo literalmente
años atrás con 2.000.000 decidió subían
de la guerra cubría fue una de las caras
oscuras de europa pero esta vez el país
se ha volcado a ayudar